tomorrow is president's day 45
individuals have held that office it's
been estimated that 545
million people have lived in this
country since we became a country and
yet only 45 men for now
have ever been called president
what do you think when you reflect on
those 45 men how many do you think
did a good job
what are your expectations for
a president do we want the person who is
best on policy the person most likely to
find consensus or the most persuasive
do we want someone we can relate to or
someone who appears larger than life do
we want a moral leader a business mind a
great public speaker
do we want a president who tells us what
we want to hear or one who tells us the
truth even if it's not what we want to
hear
there is some consensus that we like
george washington probably the same with
john adams and thomas and jefferson i've
always admired abraham lincoln because
of all he overcame the failures the
self-doubt all of which he overcame to
lead us during the most divisive time in
our country's history he seemed humble
like he took the job seriously but not
himself
i liked ronald reagan because he was
hopeful and like lincoln he experienced
defeat in life
but he came back to become one of our
most beloved presidents
my grandmother like franklin roosevelt
she was a very conservative person and
roosevelt did some very not conservative
things but she liked him
maybe we want a president we can like
america still mourns what could have
been with john f kennedy that was a loss
from which perhaps we will never recover
in the course of my lifetime only two
presidents have received more than 55
percent of the vote only two that i can
find
and yet five were elected president with
less than 50 percent of the popular vote
think about that we have not had a
consensus leader in 50 years
there have been more impeachments in my
lifetime than landslide presidential
winners so on the day we set aside to
honor presidents perhaps it's wise for
us to ask are the expectations we have
for our presidents reasonable to the
right kind of women and men seek that
office is it possible to succeed in any
office when half the people didn't want
you there in the first place
how do we even judge the success
of a president and what would it take to
find someone that perhaps
75 percent of us could rally around what
would it take to find a woman or a man
who generated real consensus someone
with a real mandate to lead this country
if we are an exceptional country
shouldn't we have exceptional leaders so
how many of our presidents would you
describe as exceptional
it may be the best way to spend
president's day is to reflect on
precisely what it is we are looking for
in a president
does the process of seeking that office
encourage the caliber
of women and men you most want to run
and serve
i guess the thing i ask myself on this
president's day is a simple but
uncomfortable question
if we struggle to find presidents we
like and respect
does that say more about us or them
there's a difference between being a
president and being a leader
and maybe the process the political
environment and the media have made it
such that the real leaders do not want
this job so we're left with those who
covet the title while we as a nation are
left to covet real leaders
i don't even know if george washington
thomas jefferson abraham lincoln or
ronald reagan would seek the job today
or if they would be nominated for the
job today or if they would win the job
today
i do know this great people should have
great leaders and if those great leaders
aren't even running
then we should ask why not
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilny and i'm
ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis